señor aceituno gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 empiezo
precisamente por preguntarle de qué se
trata este descubrimiento nuevo y cuál
es el papel de las comunidades locales
en este hallazgo
buenas tardes si realmente en el año
2018 hicimos el descubrimiento de nuevos
paneles de arte rupestre en el conjunto
de la serranía de la lindos a realmente
los hallazgos del arte rupestres se
conocen desde hace varias décadas pero
sí es cierto que en nuestro proyecto de
investigación hemos sumado nuevos
paneles en localidades en diferentes
puntos de la serranía de lalín 2a y
además también hemos hecho otros
hallazgos arqueológicos en sitios
estratificados que también es muy
relevante sobre el papel de las
comunidades ellas son claves yo lo digo
de esta manera la gente necesita a las
pinturas y las pinturas necesitan a la
gente porque realmente las comunidades
locales son las que van a gestionar esas
pinturas y son clave en la salvaguarda
de este patrimonio colombiano
suramericano y de iu de la humanidad no
ahora hablemos de la importancia de este
arte rupestre
bueno pues el arte rupestre siempre es
difícil interpretarlo porque obviamente
es adentrarnos en el pensamiento
simbólico de gentes de hace miles de
años y un avance muy importante de
nuestro proyecto de investigación es que
hemos dado
hemos puesto dijéramos fechas a cuando
entraron los primeros pobladores a esta
parte a esta región de la amazonía
colombiana yo creo que eso ha sido muy
importante y por supuesto por las
pinturas no nos dejaron sus relatos
escritos que escenas se estaban pintando
quienes las quienes las pintaban
probablemente haya todo un pensamiento
mítico chamánico escenas animalistas en
todo ese universo esotérico de estas de
estas sociedades y también probablemente
relatos de su vida cotidiana de su vida
cotidiana entonces junto a los hallazgos
arqueológicos estratificados pues las
pinturas rupestres es otro lenguaje
arqueológico obviamente nos va a ayudar
mucho sobre todo dijéramos a responder
muchas preguntas sobre estos pueblos
amazónicos no también parece eso que es
clave
son las evidencias de la serranía de
lalín 2a en este momento es esto ese
pueblo se colonizó al final de la edad
del hielo hace 12 mil 500 años yo creo
que soy muy relevante son las segundas
fechas cronológicas más antiguas de toda
la amazonía las más antiguas están la
amazonía brasileña y en lo que es la
parte alta de la región amazónica pues
son de los más antiguos y obviamente es
un hallazgo muy muy relevante